so many of us are aimless it's like
we're like why do I feel aimless people
ask me that all the time like man I feel
so anxious yeah I don't know what to do
well you know okay so two things happen
when you're aimless
okay so the first is you get anxious and
the reason you get anxious is because
anxiety computes aimlessness
so if you're if you drop someone in the
middle of a desert the reason they're
anxious is because it's not because they
don't know which way to go it's because
there are way too many places to go
right every direction and that's
aimlessness is like every direction
beckons that's way too complicated and
your brain literally signals that with
anxiety okay so that's so aimlessness
and anxiety are the same thing but it's
worse
your brain is set up to produce positive
emotion literally this is what the
positive motion system does
it computes decrease between you and a
goal so if you have a goal and you see
that you've done something that moves
you towards it your brain produces a
dopamine hit and that makes you feel
good and it strengthens the neural
circuits that moved you forward it does
both of those that's reward and
reinforcement and what that means is if
you don't have a goal you have no
positive emotion and when people say you
know they're aimless they're they're
partly telling you that they're anxious
but they're also telling you that they
have no positive emotion so then you say
well what sort of goal should you have
because that's the next question right
and the answer to that is well ask
yourself and this future authoring
program that I set up it helps you do
that it's like okay here's the deal
here's the deal
maybe this isn't true but maybe it is
you can have what you want in five years
but there's two conditions you have to
know what it is
and you have to aim at it okay okay so
let's say you're willing to play that
game might be wrong because who knows
you're going to get run over by a bus
tomorrow but you know you're going to
play the game okay now the next step is
all right
you probably want to have an intimate
relationship now maybe not but probably
but assuming you do
imagine
pretend like you're a kid
you get to have an intimate relationship
what does it look like what does it look
like when your wife greets you when you
come home from work what does your sex
life look like right what do you do for
entertainment how do you treat each
other you need a fantasy just like a
little kid playing house right
figure out what you want write it down
figure out what you could do to start
moving towards that okay do that with
your family relationships do that with
your friendships do that with your
career do that with your education think
about your misuse of alcohol and drugs
and other things that might drag you
down if you want to drink it's like you
want to be a bumbling Barney Gumble
idiot like you want to drink okay what
do you mean by that exactly how often
how much is too much how are you going
to constrain that and why develop a
vision and you have to do that in
dialogue with yourself right it's like
if I could have what I wanted
what would satisfy me and you might
think well I could never get that and I
could say well maybe not but I'll tell
you one thing man
you can move towards it and I know that
everyone who knows the underlying
Neuroscience knows this
almost all the pleasure is in the moving
toward so even you know you don't want
to set up a goal that's so high that
there's just no possibility that a
schlub like you could ever manage it but
God only knows what your upper limit is
you know but but if you set up a goal
that you think is
you know just on the edge of
conceivability then every time you move
even a tiny bit towards that you're
going to think good work man good work
you get a little kick from that you get
a little stronger from that and that
works yeah yeah you bet you bet on the
end of aimlessness at the end of
aimlessness that's the desert in Exodus
hey when when the Egyptians leave the
Pharaoh they leave tyranny right and
everybody thinks oh my God we're out of
tyranny now it's Freedom everything's
great that isn't what happens they go
into the desert they're aimless they're
slaves they have no capacity for
self-governance they have no vision of
their own they leave the Tyranny and now
they're somewhere worse they're out in
the aimless desert and part of the
reason people like tyranny even their
own is because they don't want to be
aimless in the desert it's why some
people go back to prison absolutely
absolutely it's why the after the Soviet
Union collapsed it's why so much of the
population was nostalgic for stellen you
bet it's also why Lots right there's a
story of Lord's wife when Sodom and
Gomorrah are destroyed she looks back
God turns her into a pillar of salt
right you don't look back when you
escape somewhere terrible you don't look
back and long to be there but it means
you have to develop a new vision right
if you don't develop a new vision then
you can you party you will look back
just because you want to have some
organization your brain wants to have
organization some direction right that's
right that's right you'll take here's
another rule this is a terrifying rule
if you don't provide yourself with
Direction you will take direction from a
tyrant
right
right so and you might say well why
should I take responsibility you asked
that you know it's like I'm afraid of my
own goals because of the responsibility
it's like well you're either going to be
responsible to yourself
or you're going to be responsible to a
tyrant or you're going to be absolutely
lost
that's your option set yeah right that's
it yeah
pick one tyranny slavery or something
approximating Visionary
self-determination
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one